boogying between the Isles 700 people
descended on a supermarket in building
on Saturday night transforming it into
an after-hours party venue the events
attraction included free beer non-stop
hits from a teacher team and even
bowling going out jumping rosaries but
no it's fun you get to meet people we've
been partying for 30 years but never
once in a supermarket just two hours
before it was business as usual at the
grocery store with no sign of what was
to come after hours but three friends
from the Netherlands were already
getting ready to party their students
have come from Amsterdam especially for
the disco shopping night they've already
been to two similar parties in
supermarkets I think it's a very
exclusive place to throw a party it's
weird it's just weird to dance between
your bread and your pastas and your
vegetables during the disco the
foodstuffs stay where they are after
closing time the sales floor morphs into
a dance floor a brewery supplies free
drinks organizer uist artson and his
friends help their first supermarket
disco in Amsterdam in April everybody
goose groceries and if you there's over
over again the same thing and you can
transform a thing was really people
really used to and yeah now you make it
extraordinary big and crazy and I think
we've gonna love it and we're gonna find
out today
parting in unusual venues at odd times
isn't new in many European cities like
here in London people go clubbing in the
mornings before work or at noon they
attend lunch beat parties such as here
in Stockholm
dancing in the streets or even in the
subway like here at a flash mob party in
Berlin back to Saturday night and the
supermarket manager is having a look
around
he's curious to see what the disco
organizers have done to the store
he's not too worried he might ask food I
get the feeling that everyone's waiting
for disaster and the party hasn't even
gotten underway but i'm quite sure it'll
be really relaxed and everyone will have
fun and of course it's a really special
occasion to let loose on the dance floor
disk amazing up to him no one's allowed
in yet but Luna Hawkins already in a
party mood the doors open at eleven p.m.
on the dot admission costs just under
ten euros but for that guests get a
goodie bag filled with groceries
security guard make sure people don't
take items from the store shelves but
the party mood even gets to them that
must be unlike a lot of trust why
doesn't ever want to steal everything
it's gravy in English this will never
happen but even here there's a limit to
the fun the party lasts exactly two and
a half hours still that's enough time
for a round of bowling and a chill out
session in the refrigeration section
sugar normal party there go on and on
and now we have a free party without any
drinks for half an hour if people get
really excited for a moment to open up
the doors and good shorts since the
short time a period where you can do it
and it's only once in a lifetime
experience and I think people really
energetic to to get the best out of it
along with Luna Hilton 60 other people
from the Netherlands have traveled to
Berlin especially for the party she says
it was worth the trip
I mean look at me I'm all sweaty and my
graders are falling off and it's amazing
shop and bop till you drop it's a trend
that could soon be coming to a
supermarket near you